love me a good historical biopic in this
case a biopic about someone we all
probably should have learned about in
history class but we did not so now we
get to see this person's life through a
keyhole
let's do it
so Chevalier is a biopic about the life
of Joseph Balon musical Maestro also
expert sword fighter also Marksman you
imagine something that the human body or
imagination can do and he was just good
at it a superpower he just had a
superpower that was being great at
things I was glad they touched on him
being a swordsman it's not just like oh
he's great at violin there was more to
it but more to it in real life than the
movie actually showed so there is that
now this takes place Circa France 1700s
right before the French Revolution out
the gate giving credit to Kelvin
Harrison Jr as Joseph Balon Chevalier
himself I thought it was fantastic in
the role and he generally carries the
film yes he does have some great
supporting actors working with him
Samara weaving being one of them now
this movie surprised me at being about
an hour and 45 minute run time I'm not
used to that for historical musical
biopics usually I'm I'm used to the
Amadeus that's a quantifiable run time
Amadeus it's usually like how long is
this movie uh Amadeus [__]
all right let me piss first one second
right so an hour 45 it works both for
this film and against in that same way
that your weaknesses are your strengths
just in certain situations and vice
versa case in point hour 45 minutes is
generally speaking a pretty tight run
time you're engaged for most of it that
said this movie could have and should
have been so much more I mean keeping it
vague he has this friend in the movie
and then he and his friends they seem
pretty close and they have a falling out
and he says something like I defended
you when people were besmirching your
name I wanted to be like anyone in this
theater who saw that happen could you
raise your hand
all right so it's not just me that
legitimately did not happen on screen
it's a classic case for the movie
telling you something happened without
showing you that thing happened which
means it doesn't really stick The
Landing emotionally speaking I wouldn't
doubt it it would not surprise me if I
found out later there's some three hour
cut of this film out there somewhere I
feel like this film's gonna run into
problems with audiences with one of two
scenarios you're in one of two camps one
you are skilled and versed you're a
scholar into the life of Joseph Balon in
which case you're gonna watch this film
and be like well that was a Bare Bones
could have should have been more version
of that person's life or two and this is
where I ran into it I walked out of the
movie being like that was perfectly
enjoyable it was a perfectly enjoyable
biopic absolutely then I was interested
enough to look into the life further
which is really what a biopic should
leave you with
but man this is a rare case of the real
life story being far more interesting
than this movie was yeah aside from
violin riding dancing swimming skating
fencing the movie touches on two of
those things including violin and some
of it was traded out for the sake of
entertainment but also not historically
accurate for example the way this movie
starts out is is him having a dueling
violin Showdown with Mozart for the
film's entertainment purposes it was
absolutely entertaining and pretty
awesome and I know why they did it
because people have taken to calling
Joseph balloon black Mozart which
severely undercuts him and his skills
and all that he did so it's like all
right have him whip Mozart's ass there
you go but historically not only do
these two cross paths but they lived
under the same roof at a point in fact
historians have taken some of Mozart's
music and lined it up with Joseph
balloons and they're like I'm pretty
sure Mozart stole that that to me is
more interesting but yeah you can have
him just dueling violins at the
beginning and sure also the dude fought
in war that's a huge part of his life
but we just kind of get that in the text
at the end I hope this movie is
successful in that gauging audience
interest kind of way so we can hopefully
get that HBO miniseries that this life
absolutely lends itself to this was an
interesting glimpse into a very
fascinating life but it feels like that
a glimpse if you can imagine viewing a
beautiful landscape through a keyhole
that's what this movie feels like but
for a casual viewing experience it's
perfectly enjoyable I'm gonna say it's a
good time no alcohol required caveat at
matinee price all right so Chevalier
have you seen it what did you think
about it what's your favorite historical
biopic whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]